So one thing that's really interesting to note here, is that, the remainder
that we got, when we divided x cubed minus 4 x squared plus x plus 6 by x minus
1, is the same as the number that we got when we plugged 1 in for x in this
function. That's pretty interesting. This would be a pretty incredible
coincidence, if it weren't actually caused by something. You'll also remember
that, when we plugged in 2 to our function, we ended up with 0, and we know
that x minus 2 is a factor, so if we divided by x minus 2, we would get 0 as a
remainder. Seems like remainders in the numbers we get, when we plug in
different values for a function, are very closely connected. Let's keep going
with this idea. So, what will the remainder be if we divide the function we've
been working with, instead, by x plus 3? Think for a second about what to do.
And now, I'll give you a hint. Why don't you see what happens if you just find
f of negative 3. You can still think about the connection we were seeing
before, between remainders and plugging numbers into the function. And then if
you want to, double check by doing the long division.